every inanimate object in your house is
having a conversation with you whether
you know it or not and I realize my
guitars are always saying are you just
done playing music is that who you are
now are you or my books are like are you
gonna be stupid Forever am I I've got
clothes in my closet they're like wow
remember when you used to exercise and
you weren't actually in shape are you
just gonna be fat dad now is that is
that where we're headed the dishes in
the sink are like oh you're gonna be
that husband that just hates his wife
you can be that guy I know by the way
you're hoarding hope it never it was
this light bulb that came on I'm having
10 000 conversations at the same time
the The Woodworking stuff is like oh
you're never gonna build that treehouse
for your son are you and he's gonna go
to college and you're gonna sure son
will get to it Cats in the Cradle it
never stops and so it's really almost
pathologically almost like civil I'm
trying to shut the voices up yeah and at
some point I can't compete I've got to
hand some of this stuff out right
because it won't stop and if it were to
spontaneously combust the voice to stop
yes the voices stop as well